In this lesson, we're going to talk about optimizing fog effects in Unreal and how that
works.
So let's get started.
So fog effects are one of the most expensive effects that you can use in Unreal, and especially
if you're using volumetric fog.
Now, volumetric fog, as you turn that on in Unreal, it allows you to be able to actually
isolate the fogs in such a way so it doesn't invade your interiors nor areas where they're
shaped.
Now, this is very minimal shade, but if you're inside of a room or et cetera, or just even
a simple overhang of trees, the fog will not invade those areas.
So checking that performance and making sure the most optimal settings is what we're going
to be talking about here.
Number one, we can look at profile GPU to inspect what's going on with our fog.
You can also, if you want to, choose to cast volumetric shadows in your scene, but keep
in mind this can actually increase things almost by three times the amount of heaviness
going on in your fog.
So just keep that in mind because you're actually trying to make it so that that fog is believable,
but all of that needs to be calculated in your environment.
Let's go and play with a little bit of the fog, and I'll walk you through some of the
tips and tricks and things you need to look out for, and we'll also go back to the slides.
So here we are in Unreal, and I'm going to go ahead and make sure my exponential height
fog is set correctly.
So we're going to make sure our volumetrics are on, and again, you can increase this or
decrease this, and you'll notice the scatter, and I'm talking about the scatter distribution,
also affects the light and the amount of fog coming through.
We can actually see it here also in our environment, how that is affecting and even making it so
that the lights are glowing more with the fog, such as our sunlight, but you'll notice
that or I should say this particular rec light we're looking directly at, but such things
as our spotlight over here have kind of lost some of that bloom and that cone and influence
there just by us editing the scatter distribution.
So you can keep that at 0.2 for objects you need to see more in a side angle, and you'll
see a little bit with the lights, but not as much as if we adjusted that number like
we just did.
Now the fog overall amount, we can increase, and that will also increase the effect of
our lights on those fogs, particularly one that is positioned in such a way such as this
spotlight.
Now if we want to actually edit that on a more micro level, we can go into that particular
spotlight in our scene and edit that in such a way to make sure that it also gives off
more fog influence, and that's using our volumetric scatter intensity.
That's basically the influence of the fog and the light together.
So I can increase that if I need to.
Now working with these properties, again, as you increase this influence, things can
get a little bit more expensive.
We're in a baking scenario, but some of those rules still apply when it comes to lumen.
If I go in here back to my fog properties that we have, to an exponential head fog,
then let's actually just type in it, make it easier.
There we go.
Get that exponential head fog in here.
You'll notice we also have a secondary area of data in which we can increase fog amount
overall, but also make it so that it's on a lower level.
Now we don't have any lower level geometry in this particular scene.
We do go over this in atmospheric lighting, but that also can be added into our environment.
But keep in mind, as you bring more fog into play, things can get expensive.
So make a note to itself.
Now you'll notice also in a fog environment here, we have a static underneath our volumetrics.
You'll notice we have a static lighting scattering intensity.
We have static lighting in here, a few things, not a lot, and it would increase a little
bit here such as our ground fog overall.
And you'll see that we just kind of multiplied it in that environment there.
And it's actually relating to our lights, the ones that are static.
Now if you're not working with static lighting, because Lumion does not support it, that's
really not going to help you much.
So just keep that in mind.
But that is available if you wanted to use it.
Notice we have our constant frame rate here.
On here is actually pretty nice overall.
And even though we may increase or decrease our fog, we will gain a few frames.
And as you add other elements with that fog, and especially if you add these lights that
use these scattering intensity, things can get a little bit heavy, especially if your
ICV affects and you're on stage.
And what I mean by that is your fog, plus all these elements that you have in play,
need to actually all be calculated.
And your each of your objects and materials will be counted as draw calls, as we've talked
about in other classes.
So keep those things in mind because fog is just going to add another layer of complexity.
When you can, you do want to try to use fog cards.
They have shader complexity, but they're still a little bit less in their view and how they
are seen.
And I'll bring up a scene real quick here so you can kind of see what you can do to
fake some of those effects.
This particular scene we use and show off in our atmospheric lighting course, but I wanted
to use it just for a brief moment so you can actually see how the fog cards and even volumetric
materials on simple pieces of geometry actually really kind of sell this environment.
You can see the fog cards in here slowly just moving off to the left here and using also
a fog blueprint.
And here's our volumetric fog, which is connected to a piece of geometry for a cheap ground
fog.
It's pretty great.
So whenever you can, you want to try to use fog cards and maybe even use this volumetric
material and it can be a bit cheaper.
And you can even sell the idea of fog on even a lower ground playing, such as down below
here where you can actually see different layers of fog floating around simply by putting
some fog cards in place.
So just note to yourself there just exactly how cool and how great you can actually make
some really cool scenes using a little bit of your fog or a lot.
But these fog cards can add that little icing on the cake.
And sometimes that's all you need is in fog cards just so that things in the background,
you'll get the idea of a visual representation that you're going for and they don't necessarily
have to have all the bells and whistles.
So again, three of the main players that you'll be using when it comes to your fog is one
is going to be the intensity in your light.
So it's going to relate to it just like it would in a regular world scenario where if
your light is increased in a foggy area, that light's going to bounce around on the water
particles and then they will affect the scene.
It works exactly the same way.
So if you choose to, like I said earlier, you can cast volumetric shadows if you want
more realism, but that is very expensive.
So keep that in mind.
And also the volumetric scatter intensity on each light can be adjusted for that implementing
the strength of that influence of the fog and the light relationship.
So here is some CVARs that you can use for final pixel fog optimization.
And this is the one that we use for our cinematics for Fortnite.
So this allow you to have the best possible resolution for your fog as you output them
in your render queue, in your movie render queue.
And you'll see we have volumetric fog grid size 256, r.volumetric fog.gridsize2, and
r.volumetric fog.temporal reprojection 1.
And these actually work really well.
For ICV effects, you do need to be careful of noise that may occur on your scene.
So again, whenever you can, try to use them fog cards.
They're simplistic in nature, and they definitely can be used to your advantage.
So some of the CVARs that you can use to maybe dumb down things so they're not too strong
and yet not too poorly represented is your r.volumetric fog grid size here.
It defaults at 8, but can't be lower to 6.
Anything higher than 8 can increase performance, but at the cost of pixelation.
So just keep that in mind, performance versus visuals, and also r.volumetric fog grid size
Z. This defaults at 128, lower values increase performance, and may cause pixelation like
we talked about before.
So keep that in mind.
It's a trade off visuals versus performance.
And at the bottom here, you'll see you can also turn it off to see what your fog effects
are doing to impact your performance overall.
And again, you have a few others here here, six 96 and then zero as a reminder overall
as testing points to be able to mess with things a bit.
Here's a link here for if you want to dive in a bit deeper looking at exponential height
fog.
That's it with this course.
We hope you've enjoyed what we've talked about.
In the next video, we're going to recap a bit of what we talked about.
And we're going to wrap things up and we hope you've enjoyed things.